8pm I feel like your breakfast is at
like four six A.M
[Music]
good morning I've turned on my white LED
lights and any lights I have in my room
because it's supposed to increase your
wakefulness and focus I've learned about
it and people in that podcast I'll go
quickly get my skincare done because I
want to be back on my desk studying as
soon as possible
[Music]
foreign
I do when I sit on my desk is plan my
day ahead I usually do a to-do list I'm
currently on neurology placement which
is brain and nerves so I want to do at
least 50 practice questions on the
neurology before my placement starts
then me and my placement partner will
need to go into hospital at 9am to take
a history from a patient and examine
them for our CBD which is case-based
discussion
[Music]
I try not to look at my phone and
especially go on social media accounts
until 8am which is very hard usually but
I've been getting better and better
since the exams are getting closer and
closer also I am freezing even though I
have five layers so I've got this tank
top then I've got this t-shirt long
sleeve sweatshirt blanket I'm still
freezing because I live in a student
house with other Medics and with the
current gas prices the heating is very
expensive we've decided not to turn on
the heating until December so wearing
lots of layers will have to do for
another month
[Music]
we're gonna go downstairs to the kitchen
now but the kitchen is even colder so
I'm gonna put another layer on then
we'll have a quick breakfast
foreign
[Music]
for now I try to get as much work done
as possible in the mornings because
early mornings are really my prime time
and I can focus and learn the most then
that's why my main goal is doing uni
work and I do my exercise and have my
shower and relax in the evenings because
they don't require that much focusing
and I can enjoy it more knowing that I
was productive in the morning now let's
go have a proper breakfast which is
going to be my second breakfast of the
day
foreign
[Music]
good morning are you feeling okay yeah
I'm just really cold I have two hoodies
on and this one I was freezing as well
this morning it's really chilly when are
we thinking of like turning the heating
on
I don't know yet I think you need to be
a house decision yeah because it's very
expensive
[Music]
foreign
thank you do I usually have this Clara
this kind of breakfast store I usually
have like wraps for breakfast don't you
yeah I'm gonna put wraps okay into that
as well I just wanted to be like I am
real guys I actually have this like yeah
I feel like your breakfast is at like
what 6 a.m yeah this is my second
breakfast anyway I guess we could call
it for lunch
my breakfast I think I might copy you
from now really yeah that looks really
good
so basically what I put in a wrap but
not in a wrap this time
[Music]
it doesn't have protein on the label or
really I'm just from having the Weetabix
are also protein wheat to this it's so
bad I have to stop in this protein
really yeah it's a Shaker but you have
water in it right yeah yeah okay
[Music]
it's past 8 am now I can go on my phone
now I'm going to listen some music when
I get ready I already did part of my
skincare earlier so I'm just gonna put
some sunscreen on
[Music]
I'm going to keep this under my scrubs
because sometimes in the hospitals it
can get cold too
before I go to hospital I'll talk about
my sleep schedule I go to bed around 7
00 8 p.m and I've been waking up early
throughout my life and it can be a
lonely and onto social routine I've
tried to get better at going to bed
later so I can see more of my family and
friends but it doesn't really work for
me especially during winter in the UK
the sunset is as early as 4 P.M so as
the days get shorter it's harder for me
to stay awake late also I understand
there is all that toxic hype about
waking up early to be productive but in
my opinion it depends on your circadian
rhythm so whichever hour of the day you
can learn the best so waking up early to
be productive is no better than going to
bed late to be productive and vice versa
I remember when I was a teenager I felt
like I should also pull an all-nighter
and stay awake until midnight to study
with my friends and I tried is it that I
realized I struggled to learn when the
time is past 10 11 pm so it's about
making the most of what works for you I
need to leave now but I'll be doing a q
a as it is requested by you and this is
my Instagram to ask me any questions on
there and I'll try and answer them in my
next video thank you for watching
consider subscribing and I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
this is my first video shot with a real
camera rather than my iPhone I'm still
getting used to it but thank you bye
foreign
it's so hard to use this camera
[Music]